la magie de noël dans le ciel amboisiens
12 minutes de spectacle à la nuit tombée
et des figures qui s'enchaînent pour le
plus grand plaisir du public venu en
masse c'était très bien très joli mais
magnifique assez dans les airs déjà et
c'est est synchronisé deux heures avant
les 100 drones sont minutieusement
préparée depuis l'île d'or là on a le
drone le drone sans la batterie sur
lequel on revient plus que justement ces
deux accumulateurs
dessus
et à ce moment là on peut allumer le
drone
pas de caméra dessus uniquement une led
une aide qui visible à 6 km est capable
de représenter toutes les couleurs que
l'on veut donc le drone est repositionné
comme ça sur le tapis avec tous les
copains autour de sa centaine de copains
tout autour et au moment du lancement
outre un quart d'heure avant il va
recevoir un plan de vol qui va lui
permettre justement de réaliser la danse
pendant tout le show et aux minima au
centimètre près va savoir ce qu'il a à
faire venu tout droit de lyon l'équipe
de la toute jeune compagnie allumé
vérifie tous les détails pour que le
spectacle soit parfait un travail de
plusieurs semaines qui s'est construit
en trois étapes prend n'importe qui en
consomme un spectacle sur un story board
non mais vraiment sûr assis à table en
imagine tableau un tableau de diablo iii
et on va associer ça avec de la musique
parce que la musique c'est très
important c'est tout ce qui fait le
spectacle de rhône ensuite c'est parti
c'est mobilisation mais c'est là où il
ya toutes les difficultés célia tous les
calculs tous les toutes les lignes de
codes qui ont été derrière pouvoir
modéliser nos spectacles une fois qu'on
est d'accord voilà on a plus qu'à
exporter c'est ses plans de vol dans les
drones et non classé aujourd'hui
troisième grande étape la réalisation on
installe tout et on va lancer les plans
de long est injecté dans les drones et
puis la magie le cancer ce spectacle de
drones haut en couleur était une
première en indre et loire
de quoi donner des idées au château et
monuments du val de loire
[Musique]